bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
émission de débat de chroniques et de
reportage 90 minutes pour donner du sens
à l'actualité comme tous les soirs du
lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h sur Public
Sénat c'était il y a 2 mois jour pour
jour victime de la pire attaque
terroriste de son histoire Israël
basculait dans l'horreur et perdait
beaucoup de ses certitudes sécuritaires
depuis la poste a fait des milliers de
morts côté palestinien et après une
trêve fragile les combats ont repris
dans le sud de la bande de Gaza est-ce
possible de mettre le Hamas hors d'état
de nuire comment sortir dans ce qui
apparaît de plus en plus comme une
impasse stratégique on en débat dans une
minute et puis c'est un mot que je vous
propose d'analyser dans la seconde
partie de notre émission
réindustrialisation depuis 2017 le solde
de la création d'usine dans notre pays
est positif avec plus de 300 nouveau
sites
après 30 ans de désindustrialisation
nous voyons les usines se réimplanter
les investisseurs étrangers choisir la
France après les 30 piteuses il est
l'heure des 30 prometteuses c'est le
choix que nous faisons pour la France et
l'engagement que nous prenons vis-à-vis
des Français ce phénomène prometteur
peut-il durer est-il compatible avec les
nouvelles règles environnementales
permet-il de créer beaucoup d'emploi
réponse avec nos experts dans 3IS qu4
d'heure mais d'abord la guerre dans la
bande de Gaza les combats les plus
violents se concentrent autour de
ranunes Jérôme Rabier de mois jour pour
jour après l'attaque du Hamas sur Israël
l'État hébreu poursuit sa progression
dans la bande de Gaza au sud de
l'enclave canonis supposé bastion du
Hamas est désormais quotidiennement sous
les bombes et les incursions de soldats
israéliens se font de plus en plus
profondes dans la ville notamment pour
tenter de capturer yayassin noir chef du
Hamas dans la bande de
Gazin j'ai dit que nos forces pouvaient
aller n'importe où dans la bande de Gaza
elles encerclent actuellement la maison
de sinoir sa maison n'est pas son
château et il peut s'enfuir mais ce
n'est qu'une question de temps avant que
nous le
trouvions les opérations israéliennes se
déroulent dans un secteur où beaucoup de
Gazaoui sétent réfugiés après le début
de l'offensive dans le nord de l'enclave
80 % des plus de 2 millions de Gazaoui
ont désormais quitter leur domicile
cherchant en vain un refuge de mois dans
les rues à passé d'un endroit à l'autre
d'un côté à l'autre ce sont les de mois
les plus difficiles que nous ayons connu
dans notre
vie la situation sur place et critique
comme ici devant un centre de
distribution d'une agence de l'ONU où la
foule se presse à tel point qu'Antonio
goutierrez secrétaire général des
Nations Unies a décidé d'invoquer
l'article 99 de l'organisation une
première depuis
1971 une manière d'insister sur
l'ampleur de la crise secrétaire général
exorte les membres du Conseil de
sécurité à faire pression pour éviter
une catastrophe humanitaire et réitère
ça demande qu'un cess lefeu humanitaire
soit instauré une demande immédiatement
rejetée par Israël qui dénonce les
positions de l'ONU soutenue par son
allié américain l'État hébreu mis sur
son véau pour bloquer toute initiative
internationale qui le freinerait dans
son
offensive Gaza la ripost à quel prix
c'est le thème de notre débat avec Agnès
Levallois bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes maîtresse de recherche à la
Fondation pour la recherche stratégique
et vice-présidente de l'Institut de
recherche et d'études Méditerranée
Moyen-Orient bnabli bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes professeur de droit à lupec
Paris 12 consultant international au
cabinet lisias partner et auteur de ce
livre relation international droit
théorie et pratique paru aux éditions
pédon Laurence Saim bonsoir et bienvenue
ancienne correspondante en Israël et aux
États-Unis Laur et et j'accueil émilyie
zapelski éditorialiste pour s public
bienvenue Émilie euh on va démarrer puis
assez vite évidemment on va essayer de
tirer des leçons un peu plus générales
mais on l'a vu avec le le le sujet
d'ouverture de Jérôme Rabier agè
qu'est-ce qui se passe à à à ranues
pourquoi l'armée cible-t-elle cette
ville il y a des il y a des voilà il y a
il y a des leader du Hamas qui serait
sur place c'est ça oui parce que c'est
une ville effectivement qui abrité alors
on sait pas si les responsables du Hamas
ils sont encore mais qui abrité les
responsables du Hamas et surtout c'est
la stratégie d'Israël qui après avoir
bombardé le nord de la de Gaza et bien
s'attaque maintenant à cette grande
ville du Sud effectivement avec l'idée
qu'il se trouent des combattants du
Hamas et donc ils sont dans la logique
de la progression que netanahou a
annoncé à savoir aller chercher les
combattants là où ils se trouvent et
donc de détruire les infrastructures et
pas simplement les infrastructures du
Hamas mais de détruire aussi un certain
nombre de maisons supposé abriter
éventuellement des membres du Hamas et
avec une situation qui est absolument
dramatique puisque les Gazaoui qui
étaient au nord de la bande de gaz
l'armée israélienne leur a dit d'aller
dans le sud et donc maintenant ils sont
dans le sud et l'armée israélienne leur
demande de partir mais pour aller où
avec interdiction de revenir dans le
Nord puisque l'idée d'Israël maintenant
c'est de faire une zone tampon
finalement avec l'État d'Israël et donc
une situation comme une sourissière si
je pu dire même si ce terme est
absolument épouvantable mais les
Gazaouis sont complètement pris au piège
sans pouvoir partir et donc sans sans
pouvoir trouver une issue à cette
situation est-ce qu'il pourrait sortir
côté côté égyptien parce que finalement
cette cette barrière Arafa on on
pourrait imaginer le le peuple
palestinien la faire sauter sauf qu'il
reste là qu'est-ce que ça signifie ça ça
signifie tout simplement que l'Égypte
est un État souverain et que son chef
d'État refuse cette
perspective notamment au regard de
l'histoire du peuple palestinien qui a
été balloté dès l'ors qu'ils ont accepté
l'option du du refuge ou de devenir
réfugié ben c'est en FA et puis le refus
d'un nouvel exode aussi il y a a la BL
sû de 48 je pense qu'il y a peut-être ça
aussi oui bien sûr c'est c'est en cela
que l'option ou l'hypothèse qui a été
évoquée par d'autres et qui est rêvé par
un certain nombre de responsables
israéliens en fait est refusé à la fois
par les Égyptiens parce qu'en fait dès
lors que vous acceptez de de tels
réfugiés leur statut transitoire
basculle historiquement en statut quasi
permanent en tout cas au regard de ce
qui s'est passé pour les réfugiés
palestiniens au Liban euh en Jordanie
naturellement voir en Syrie et donc donc
il y a un refus des Égyptiens de de de
pouvoir traduire en acte cette hypothèse
là et puis naturellement les
Palestiniens eux-mêmes de Gaza refusent
de de tomber dans ce piège parce que il
s'agit en réalité d'un piège qui est
conçu aussi comme un scénario plausible
côté
israélien donc donc aujourd'hui la
question est de savoir si côté égyptien
on va céder finalement à une forme de
pression démographique humanitaire euh
et est-ce que les Palestiniens eux-mêmes
vont finalement céder également à cette
situation de catastrophe humanitaire
qu'ils subissent et grosso modo est-ce
que finalement la seule option que
représente cette hypothèse là n'est pas
finalement une option qui relève de la
survie des
Palestiniens un témoignage on en a
entendu dans le dans le SU allez-y mais
je vous redonner la parole juste après
vous inqu juste pour dire juridiquement
on est quand même dans du transfert
forcé voire du nettoyage ethnique je on
le dit depuis le début mais on a
tellement normalisé les choses qu'on est
euh on est dans des crimes
internationaux alors on y reviendra
évidemment j'avais prévu cette question
mais je voulais vous proposer un
témoignage d'un de ces habitants qui qui
fuit la zone des des combats cet homme
qui arrive avec ses affaires pour monter
des tentes dans euh une zone de de Rafa
on l'écoute ne sommes-nous pas des êtres
humains dont les autres devrait se
soucier ne sommes-nous pas des musulmans
jusqu'à quand les gens seront-ils
déplacés jusqu'à quand serons-nous tués
Arafa nous ne trouverons ni eau ni
toilette ni endroit où dormir pour nos
enfants honte à vous craignez Dieu
Laur on peine à à imaginer ces ces
combats dans dans cette ville vous avez
vécu à à Gaza à quoi peut ressembler
ranunes aujourd'hui avec cette densité
de population c'est et vous avez raison
de le souligner il y a une densité de
population il y a 10 à 15 personnes qui
vivent dans chaque maison chacun sait ce
qui se passe unes c'est à l'extérieur de
Gaza c'est là où shak Yassin le
fondateur du Hamas vivait où il y avait
des mosquées où Hamas a fait en 2006 une
campagne électorale très importante pour
réhabiliter l'aide qui n'avait pas été
acheminée par l'argent de l'Europe par
l'argent des États-Unis mais détourné
par l'Autorité palestinienne et donc
c'est aussi un bastion du Hamas et
l'attitude israélienne c'est de dire on
doit en finir avec Hamas alors est-ce
que c'est une attitude que l'Occident
peut comprendre ou pas pas c'est le
problème parce que il y a énormément de
victimes civiles et tout le monde voit
en ce moment en permanence 24h/ 24 sur
les réseaux sociaux sur les chaînes de
télévision ces images absolument atroces
d'une guerre enue en action il y a pas
de réponse à ça les Israéliens sont
déterminés à faire en sorte que le
massacre du 7 octobre ne se reproduisent
jamais ils sont persuadés qu'il faut
aller jusqu'au bout ils n'écoutent
personne lorsque les diplomates
américains commencent à leur dire
attendez vous ne pouvez pas faire ce que
vous êtes en train de faire ils disent
vous n'avez pas eu le 7 octobre le 7
octobre devient la justification pour
Benjamin netaniaou et son gouvernement
de faire ce qui se passe à gazar c'est
en train de créer une génération perdue
la paix on ne la verra pas et il faut
pas se raconter d'histoire ce qu'on voit
là on ne verra nous dans notre
génération jamais la paix des deux côtés
la blessure maintenant est trop
et c'est cette leçon de ces de mois de
guerre en vous entendant je pense à
l'émission qu'on faisait hier une partie
de l'émission était consacré à Nelson
Mandela et à sa capacité au pardon quand
il est sorti après 27 années de de
prison mais je ne sais pas si
a en ce moment quel est le nelon mand
parce que vous avez un discours qui qui
est très définitif sur le fait vous
dites bon on a peut-être si tout va bien
quelques décennies de vie encore les uns
les autres on verra pas la paix quoi je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez non c'est
vrai que quand on voit la situation
aujourd'hui avec ce jusqu'au bouhisme de
netanahù c'est
évidemment épouvantable puisqu'on voit
bien que rien l'arrête alors les
Américains pourrai l'arrêter et
qu'est-ce qui empêche les Américains
d'arrêter de livrer les munitions dont a
besoin Israël pour mener cette opération
de
cés je sais bien qu'il y a une raison
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que si on regarde les choses froidement
les Américains peuvent se permettre ils
ont un outil entre les mains qu'ils
n'utilisent pas pour des raisons de
politique intérieure mais l'outil existe
je rappelle 91 qui est quand même un
très bon exemple au lendemain de la 2è
guerre du Golf lorsqu'on met en avant le
deux poids de mesure de la politique
américaine qui fait respecter les
résolutions de l'ONU pour faire partir
les troupes irakiennes du kweit les
Américains se rendent compte que ils ont
jamais fait appliquer les résolutions
concernant le conflit israalpalestinien
il proposent une conférence de paix à
Madrid les Israéliens ne veulent pas y
mettre les pieds à l'époque ils ont
besoin de 3 milliards de dollars et les
Américains disent vous vos 3 milliards
de dollars tant que vous n'accepterez
pas d'aller à la conférence de Madrid au
bout de 3 mois chamir Premier ministre
israélien de du lcou a fini par rendre
les armes si je pu dire et aller à la
conférence on sait ce qu'ils en ont fait
les Israéliens ils n'en voulaient pas
lier ce que je veux dire c'est que il y
a un levier et que ce levier il faudrait
effectivement qu'il puisse être actionné
même si je sais que le timing pour
parler en bon français et le pire soit
on y reviendra à la situation aux
États-Unis vous vouliieez prendre la
parole oui simplement moi je suis très
étonné en fait de cette situation parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'on se réveille
il y a eu un soutien quand même d'Israël
par rapport à cette attaque terroriste
on le comprend bien mais un soutien qui
était peut-être un peu naïf parce que là
tout d'un coup on se réveille en se
disant et ben oui il veut aller jusqu'au
bout probablement déplacer des
populations comme vous l'avez dit forcé
par la pression de son action militaire
forcé avec ce pr enfin c'est pas un
prétexte c'est une réalité c'est un
objectif de combattre le Hamas jusqu'au
bout et on a l'impression qu'on se
réveille tout d'un coup en se disant ah
oui il est capable de ça ah oui il se
passe ça à Gaza et alors al que
globalement on avait les signaux comme
vous le disiez tout à l'heure on les
avait les signaux que probablement ça
prendrait ses dimensions sauf qu' on
peut plus arrêter le train on sait pas
comment faire parce qu'il n'y a pas de
poids international suffisant à part les
États-Unis probablement pour arrêter les
choses ou en tout cas les freiner on
viendra à cette question de de de
stratégie si t qu' qu' en a une côté
netaniaahou et cabinet de guerre mais je
voudrais quand même on est à 2 mois jour
pour jour de de de l'attaque terroriste
du du ramas et donc il y a eu un certain
nbre dommages qui ont été rendus
aujourd'hui en Israël je vous propose
ces images et ces mots forts du
président israélien Isac Herzog il est
sur le site du festival de de musique la
rêve parti
Nova cher famillees on deuiller héros et
héroïn survivant du festival et toute la
communauté Nova bien-aimé il semble que
depuis le plus noir des Chabbat noir du
7 octobre il n'y ait pas une seule
personne en Israël dont le cœur ne
s'arrête lorsque l'horloge indique
exactement 6h29 le matin cette heure est
une faille dans le temps une blessure
béante pour tout un peuple un abîme qui
sépare le monde qui l'a précédé et les
jours les mois brûlants dans lesquels
nous sommes tombés depuis des jours que
même si nous le souhaitons nous devons
accepter apprendre à vivre et dans
lesquels nous devons retrouver la force
de choisir le bien de nous accrocher à
la
vie évidemment personne ici ne minimise
le le le le traumatisme subi par par
Israël mais je pense que c' important
aujourd'hui de d'entendre çaab est-ce
que ça veut dire je voudrais qu'on sonde
un peu l'opinion israélienne est-ce que
ça veut dire que on est encore dans le
temps du deuil mais aussi de la
vengeance d'une certaine façon c'est ça
ce à quoi on
assiste de la vengeance c'est sûr euh et
on y reviendra du deuil aussi
ou pour ce qui est de des images qu'on
vient de voir c'est des images
authentiques au sens où on a quand même
à faire un
homme politique mais il ne joue pas il
exprime quelque chose qui à mon avis est
partagé par l'écrasante majorité des
israélien et qui nous parle parce que en
vérité au-delà de la population du
peuple israélien c'est un discours fondé
sur ce qui fait notre humanité donc on
devrait tous être sensible à cel moi ce
qui me trouble c'est que le même
président
israélien puisse par ailleurs ailleurs
également tenir des discours
déshumanisant littéralement l'autre les
Palestiniens le Palestinien puisque sans
le citer littéralement il a quand même
considéré que finalement l'attaque du 7
octobre avait pour responsable les
Palestiniens et pas se en assimilant en
assimilant les civils euh au terroristes
du Hamas qui ont perpétré le massacre du
7 octobre d'une certaine manière il a
donc autorisé moralement et
politiquement les massacres auxquels on
assiste depuis le lendemain du 7 octobre
donc pour moi dans le long terme c'est
ça qui me pose question pourquoi parce
que parallèlement ce n'est pas n'importe
quel chef d'État c'est un c'est une
démocratie qui se revendique en plus
comme étant la démocratie de la région
l'unique mais l'image et le comportement
à la fois de ces responsables politiques
et de son armée ne sont pas dignes de
l'idéal démocratique qui est précisément
attaqué par tous les ennemis de la
démocratie dans la région et au-delà je
pense au chinois et au russes ou oui
mais après c'est à quel niveau on met le
curseur de la Rost la difficulté parce
que nos démocraties es doivent aussi se
défendre contre terrorisme et des
attaques comme cell alors le niveau vous
avez absolument raison de le dire le
seuil il est fixé par le droit
international précisément parce qu'on a
affaire à une démocratie qui se présente
comme étant un état de droit mais est-ce
que le droit international rend une Rost
possible bien sû mais bien sûr ça
s'appelle la légitime défense mais qui
n'est pas absolue elle est encadrée par
un principe qui est celui de la
proportionnalité tout cela on devrait on
devrait même pas le rappeler parce que
ça relève d'un esprit de civilité de
civilisation on ne peut pas d'un côté
précisément faire comme font trop de
responsables occidentaux céder au
discours maniquéen du Bien contre le Mal
et de l'autre oublier précisément ce qui
devrait incarner le bien le respect des
valeurs démocratiques c'est-à-dire
reconnaître notamment l'humanité de
l'autre et en même temps respecter la
loi commune le droit international dès
lors qu'on a AFF faire à une armée qui
fait fi de toutes les normes de toutes
les lois internationales il y a un
problème euh il y a il y a dans dans
l'actualité de ce de ce jeudi il y a des
photos Laurence Saï qui ont été dévoilé
publié de du comportement de de soldats
israéliens avec des prisonniers
palestiniens c'est ça oui c'est sorti
cet après-midi voilà alors de de de quoi
on parle et surtout quel l'impact ça
peut puisquon est dans un chapitre
consacré à l'opinion israélienne quel
impact ça peut avoir dans l'opinion
israélienne d'près vous de quoi on parle
d'abord on parle de raid qui ont été
menés par l'armée israélienne à Gaza
avec une communication voulue par
l'armée israélienne et par les
communicants qui conseillent Benjamin
netaniaahou de montrer ce que l'armée
israélienne fait en arrêtant selon les
Israéliens des suspects terroristes
affiliés au Hamas les photos vont
choquer l'opinion publique globale et
les photos à mon sens vont renforcer
c'est un sentiment
anti-israélien de ce qui se passe parce
que il y a des photos qui rappellent ce
que les Américains ont fait au moment de
la guerre en Irak vous allez voir des
dizaines d'hommes qui sont en slip les
yeux bandés à genoux avec des soldats
israëlien derrière vous allez voir des
hommes qui sont dans un camion là aussi
torsenu avec une voiture avec une
mitrailleuse à l'avant de l'image et
donc on est quand on voit ces images ce
sont des images assez violentes mais ces
images encore une fois sont diffusées
pour montrer que la lutte contre le
terrorisme est implacable moi je
voudrais
simplement je voudrais simplement dire
que euh je voudrais répondre à vous
parce que je vous estime beaucoup et je
vous respecte beaucoup et je pense que
la pai ça se passe aussi toujours par le
dialogue par l'entente par la
compréhension quand vous faites quand
même un sondage en ce moment à ramala en
6 Jordanie vous voyez quand même que la
majorité des Palestiniens soutient ce
qui s'est passé le 7 octobre et
considère que le Hamas a eu raison ça
c'est pas du militantisme c'est un fait
et donc lorsque vous parlez à des
Israéliens ils ont toujours cette
argument mais que peut-on faire parce
que c'est quoi on va avoir le 7 octobre
se répéter parce que on ne peut plus
faire la paix la paix est impossible et
donc on est dans la spirale d'une
violence ingérable avec des gens qui se
disent voilà c'est maintenant la lutte
contre le terrorisme de manière
implacable où on va mourir et l'autre
chose que je voudrais souligner c'est
qu'on parle du humanité on parle de
violence et cetera mais les otages ça
divise l'opinion publique israélienne de
manière profonde Benjamin nétienou a eu
une réunion hier avec des familles
d'otage ça s'est très mal passé donc des
familles d'otage qui sont toujours en
otage ou des otages qui avent été
libérés des familles d'otage dont les
otages sont toujours à Gaza avec un
degré émotionnel extraordinaire en
Israël la nation israélienne au-delà de
la division politique est unie autour de
cette question des otages et on l'a vu
lors de la libération des premiers
otages et bien des familles d'otages qui
sont toujours détenu à Gaza ont été voir
le Premier ministre israélien hier et
son cabinet de guerre ça s'est
horriblement mal passé il y a eu des
cris les familles d'otage ont dit à
néaniiaahou qu'il faisaient n'importe
quoi en ce moment qu'il fallait arrêter
et qu'il voulait à tout prix que les
otages ne soient pas sacrifiés il faut
surveiller cette question d'otage en ce
moment ça pose la question qu'on a déjà
évoqué ici de l'avenir politique d'un
benamin netaniahou mais c'est pas pour
pour tout de suite je voudrais revenir
sur les mots que vous avez employé tout
à l'heure vous avez je pense ne pas me
tromper parler d'épuration ethnique
c'est le son les term nettoyage
nettoyage ethnique c'est pour ça que
j'ais c'est pour ça
que en commençant ma phase je disais
quels étaient les mots nettoyage
ethnique est-ce que vous les approuvez
ou moi je considère aujourd'hui
qu'effectivement à Gaza on est dans
cette stratégie de nettoyage echnique
avec l'idée de faire partir cette
population et on voit bien dans les
propos qui sont tenus et dans les actes
qui sont menés aujourd'hui par par
l'armée israélienne quand l'armée
israélienne dit à la population de
quitter le nord pour aller dans le sud
et qu'après on bombarde le sud et
simplement l'armée israélienne qui dit
mais en fait on fait les choses
proprement parce qu'on envoie des
tractes avec un QR code pour dire où la
population peer se réfugier d'abord pour
lire un QR code il faut avoir internet
il faut avoir l'électricité et on sait
que aujourd'hui tout ça ne fonctionne
pas et que même les informations qui
sont donné de toute façon ne
correspondent pas à la réalité donc on
est dans une stratégie où si
effectivement pour reprendre ce qu'on a
dit tout au début si l'Égypte ouvre la
frontière elle est responsable d'une
deuxième narba la fameuse catastrophe he
C et que je rappelle que 70 % de la
population de Gaza est descendant de
réfugiés donc le spectre de 48 du départ
forcé de 48 et dans la tête de tous les
Gazaoui parce que eux-mêmes sont à 70 %
des descendants de réfugiés donc cette
option n pas une à moins qu'à la fin la
vie soit tellement insupportable qu'il
partte et on sait qu'il y a des
pressions sur pour sur l'Égypte pour que
l'Égypte yp installe les les Gazaouis
dans le sinaai mais on voit bien que
cette option est une option qui n'est
pas tenable pour les raisons que l'on
vient d'évoquer donc pour toutes ces
raisons il y a cette volonté de la part
d'Israël de faire partir les Gazaoui
mais le seul problème c'est queil y a
nul part où aller et c'est pas l'Europe
qui va accueillir les les les les
milliers ou les centaines de milliers de
Gazaoui qui sont donc on est dans une
espèce d'unasse là aussi un pass
stratégique mais la volonté me
semble-t-il est quand même très clair et
dans cet impass stratégique Bab a aussi
effectivement et ça reprend ce que vous
disez la la question de la
représentativité palestinienne qui
pourrait représenter les Palestiniens en
dehors du
ramas c'est une question bien sûr qui se
pose qui est très légitime mais elle
c'est pas la question qui se pose au
trop c'est trop tôt euh non disons
qu'elle était encore plus légitime avant
l'attaque et c'est en ça que ça rebond
enfin que c'est une question qui qui une
forme de réponse à ce que vous avez
souigné à ir que vous avez une
proportion importante de Palestiniens
aujourd'hui qui soutiennent le Hamas
c'est parce que aussi N a pas l'orreur
de ce qui s'est passé il considère que
le ramas a eu raison oui parce que c'est
pas le seul fait qui qui qui les habite
c'est aussi le fait d'avoir d' passer à
côté d'autres choses qui n'y a pas eu le
choix d'une certaine manière je veux
dire par là l'alternative politique
est-ce qu'elle a existé à un moment
donné pour les Palestiniens je rappelle
que l'Autorité palestinienne aussi
corrompu soit-elle et on le sait
hune des rais son éche aussi et de son
rejet par les Palestiniens aussi mais
malgré tout
stratégiquement Mamoud Abbas lorsqu'il a
accédé à la présidence avec le soutien
des États-Unis et des dirigeants
israélien sa feuille de route était très
claire rejet de la violence stratégie
diplomatique et bien cette stratégie
c'est choix fort soutenu par des
Palestiniens en particulier en C
Jordanie a abouti à un échec cuisant
parce que rejeté pas soutenu en tous les
cas ni par les Occidentaux ni par Israël
donc à partir du moment où vous êtes
confronté à cette réalité implacable à
savoir que en vérité concrètement les
accords d'Oslo puisqu'ils ont existé
lorsque Mahmoud Abbas est arrivé au
pouvoir n'ont pas été mis en œuvre
concrètement et qu' contraire une
politique de colonisation à continué à
se développer je veux dire par là que
derrière les m c'est un c'est des
réalités alors qui ont pesé sur le
quotidien des Palestiniens ils
constatent ce décalage là donc comment
faire très vite il y a encore beaucoup
de thèm à aborder très vite échec total
de l'Autorité palestinienne et
corruption absolue et c'est ce que les
Américains n'ont cessé de répéter et les
accords d'Oslo et on va pas refaire
toute l'histoire ici mais à un moment
donné Yasser Arafat avait tout sur la
table et c'est Yasser Arafat qui a
rejeté à un moment donné ce qui s passé
demand à
de Jérusalem il quand
même blocage un mot le blocage c'est la
colonisation qui n'a cessé alors qu'elle
devait cesser à la signature des
accords journalist référence en la
matière c'est Charlin rappelle toujours
querespondette réé pard c'est moi qui
vais décider un moment je dois êre
patron autoritaire aussi parce qu'il y a
tellement de choses passionnantes et
importantes et on peut pas refaire toute
l'histoire des du processus de paix
israpestinien vous le comprendrez bien
dans surtout que il y a il y a un fait
quand même important qu'on peut
qualifier d'historique c'est cette
initiative du Secrétaire général de
l'ONU Antonio gtiérrez qui a déclenché
l'article 99 de la Charte des Nations
Unies est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
de quoi il s'agit pour commencer agè
lovalo en fait il s'agit d'un article
qui permet de de d'alerter en cas de
danger et donc gouterz estime que
aujourd'hui la situation à Gaza relève
de cette de ce danger pour la communauté
internationale et dans le cadre des
rapports de force internationaux donc
c'est une mesure annoncée par gteres qui
est extrêmement forte même si on peut
douter de l'efficacité mais en tous les
cas je trouve que c'est un signal
extrêmement fort et un côté vraiment
courageux parce qu'on sait que gteres
depuis le début de ce conflit est
vraiment très critiqué par les
Israéliens et donc là il y a une volonté
en fait un peu de mettre le point sur la
table de la part de l'ONU qui est quand
même normalement le gendarme du monde
c'est une première depuis 52 ans hein on
l'a dit dans d'ouverture et c'est même
plus un peu plus que ça dans la mesure
où c'est une manière de mettre la
pression sur les États-Unis parce que il
invite en fait le Conseil de sécurité à
se saisir de la question à appeler un
cesser le feu sachant qu'il y a quelques
semaines une résolution une proposition
de résolution qui a été débatue par le
Conseil de sécurité et appelant à un tel
cesser le feu a été rejeté à cause du
véau américain et là le secrétaire
général en réalité fait un acte de déf
com laonsabilité américaine dans la
continuité de cette guerre et dans la
manière dont elle est menée donc je
trouve que c'est très très fort c'est
une manière de de transformer les
États-Unis en coresponsable de cette
guerre pratiquement mais qu'est-ce qui
va se passer rien il va rien se passer
parce que quand vous avez couvert l'ONU
comme je l'ai souvent couvert dans des
crises absolument épouvantable du Soudan
à la Somalie au famines à des guerres et
Cera tout le monde se rit des petites
salles à New York dans l'immeuble et il
se passe rien et tout le monde entend
les résolutions les discours attendez va
pas y avoir une réunion du Conseil de
sécurité où tout le monde prendra la
parole et dira oui ou non pour un
qu'est-ce qui se passera sur le terrain
benah je vais vous dire al simplement
une séquence où les États-Unis vont vont
être confrontés à la question de savoir
s'ils vont utiliser à nouveau leur véau
après les images que vous avez rappé
pour pour ce qui se passe sur le terrain
et c'est vraiment tout le débat qu'on a
chaque fois qu'il y a des crises par
rapport au rôle de l'ONU qu'est-ce qui
se passe pour les gens qui sou sur le
terrain rien et quand vous êtes dans des
camps de réfugiés quand vous êtes avec
des gens qui souffrent qui sont sur les
bombes ils disent l'ONU il discute nous
on souffre il ne se passe rien raison
mais imaginez que les États-Unis
utilisent leur véau ça les placera dans
une position mais pratiquement
indéfendable sur la scène internationale
et à l'inverse imaginez qu' laisse
passer via une abstention cette
résolution à planant cesser le feu là il
mettront Israël à l'inverse dans une
position où ils seront complètementol
donne la parole tout de suite Émilie
Israël réagit de cette façon par la voix
de du ministre des Affaires étrangères
et Cohen je vous cite ce ce tweet le
mandat de guterz constitue un danger
pour la paix mondiale il retourne
l'argument de guérz qui dit voilà
organisons cette ce Conseil de sécurité
parce que laappai mondiale est en danger
ça demande d'activation de l'article 99
appel au CC le feu constitue un soutien
à l'organisation terroriste ramas
approbation du meurtre de personnes
àâgées de l'enlèvement de bébé du viol
de femme quiconque soutient la paix
mondiale doit soutenir la libération de
Gaza du Hamas vous vouliez intervenir
oui je je je suis d'accord avec Laurence
dans le sens où on sait que les
décisions de l'ONU ne donnent pas
grand-chose de concret mais je pense que
symboliquement et ne serait-ce que les
mots qu'on a prononcé aujourd'hui et
qu'on commence à entendre de nettoyage
ethnique qu'on osait à peine dire du
bout des lèvres il y a quelques temps
commence à être dit ces images dont vous
avez parlé qui risquent de marquer
l'opinion publique à la fois d'Israël
mais aussi de tout l'international je
pense que c'est des symboles très très
forts on sait que ça peut changer les
choses dans la manière de voir et on
sent qu'il y a quand même un glissement
sur quelque chose qui serait plus d'un
d'un soutien aussi fort à Israël donc
même s'il y a pas des décisions qui
peuvent être prises parce que qui a la
main sur sur ces questionsl il y a quand
même quelque chose de l'ordre de
attention à ce qui se passe à Gaza
attention avec cette politique jusqu'au
bouhiste d'Israël et je pense que ça
peut c'est symbolique mais c'est très
fort en terme de communication et on
sait qu'il y a cette guerre d'image qui
compte quand même beaucoup dans opinion
je pense qu'il faut juste dire que
goteres aussi a en tête que 130 membres
de l'ONU des fonctionnaires de l'ONU
sont morts dans cette guerre à Gaza
depuis le début et il y en a sûrement
d'autres parce que tous les morts n'ont
pas été voilà
donc voilà donc il y a aussi cette
préoccupation de marquer aussi alors on
a commencé à parler évidemment du rôle
des États-Unis on va se
concentrer maintenant pendant plusieurs
minutes sur ce chapitre je propose à Tam
tranui de nous rejoindre on va parler
avec vous Tam
bonsoir on va parler des universités
américaines ditous oui parce qu'il y a
une vidéo qui tourne en boucle sur les
réseaux sociaux depuis mardi sur cette
vidéo et bien on voit les trois
présidentes d'université américaines
parmi les plus prestigieuses Harvard Pen
state le MIT elles sont auditionnées par
la Chambre des représentants notamment
par l'élu républicaine de l'État de New
York c'est e stéphanic par ailleurs
ancienne étudiante de Harvard et voici
leurs
échanges
uling har yes or no indiv not MAK
stats yes or no calling for the genocide
of Jews does not constitute bullying and
harassment I have not heard calling for
the genocide for Jews on our campus but
youve heard chance for
in I've heard chance which can be
antisemitic depending on the context
when calling for the elimination of the
Jewish people if it ised and SAS it is
har
ça dépend du contexte voilà donc ce que
répondent les trois présidents
d'université face à l'élu républicaine
qui vous l'avez vu est exaspéré elle
n'est pas la seule à avoir été consterné
par ses propos regardez la réaction du
porte-parole de la Maison Blanche c'est
Andrew Bates il a dit c'est incroyable
qu'il soit nécessaire de dire cela les
appels au génocide sont monstrueux et
contraire à tout ce que nous
représentons en tant que pays alors pour
bien comprendre ces ces arguments
comment comment ont-elles justement
argumenté qu'est-ce qu'elles ont dit en
détail pendant ces audition pour
l'essentiel elles ont justifié leurs
propos en expliquant que les appels au
génocide des juifs étaient odieux en
désaccord avec leurs valeurs et cell de
les de leurs établissements mais car oui
il y avait un ma mais que ces appels
étaient protégés par la liberté
d'expression un principe qui est garanti
par le premier amendement de la
Constitution américaine voici ce que dit
ce premier amendement sur ce sujet le
Congrès n'adoptera aucune loi pour
limiter la liberté d'expression de la
presse ou le droit des citoyens de se
réunir pacifiquement les États-Unis ils
ont une vision absolue absolutiste de la
liberté d'expression qui pour eux
protègeent même les discours de haine
c'est ainsi par exemple que le discours
du cuclux clan a été protégé depuis un
arrêt de
1969 qui fait d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
jurisprudence c'est l'arrêt Brandenbourg
qui a aussi déjà permis à des néonazis
de défiler en toute légalité en 2017 à
Charlotteville il brandissait alors des
croix gamé en en criant leur haine des
Juifs et à l'époque déjà il y a eu un
débat qui est né mais ceux qui
défendaient la liberté d'expression
absolue sont resté alors majoritaire
donc si je vous comprends bien cette
prise de position des trois présidentes
d'université n'est pas si surprenante
elle s'intègre également dans un
contexte qui est particulièrement tendu
dans ces grandes universités américaines
oui car la communauté étudiante se
déchire depuis le 7 octobre depuis la
date de l'attaque du Hamas contre Israël
on va prendre le cas de Harvard par
exemple on va un peu remonter dans le
temps dès le lendemain le 8 octobre il y
a une trentaine d'étudiants qui ont
cossigné une tribune pour dénoncer je
cite le régime d'aparteille d'Israël
responsable de toutes les violences et
très vite et bien l'affaire a pris un
tour politique avec des élus dont E
Élise Stéphanie qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure qui appelle à une réponse très
ferme et donc il a eu une autre réponse
d'autres étudiants qui ont dénoncé eux
les signataires du communiqué
proalestinien et ils ont même affiché
les images des premiers simatar sur des
camionnettes associées à l'adjectif
antisémite inversement et bien on voit
VO des témoignages d'étudiants juifs qui
ont peur qui se multiplient ils se
sentent isolés il voit aussi se
multiplier les actes antisémites il y a
eu notamment le cas de cet étudiant de
cornel qui a été arrêté parce qu'il
avait menacé de poignarder de tuer tous
les hommes juifs de violer les femmes de
décapiter les bébés juifs et face à cela
bien la réaction des directions
d'université elle est jugé bien timoré e
Stéphanie qu'on a vu tout à l'heure a
appelé à la démission des trois
présidentes qui ont été auditionnées
cette semaine elle n'est pas la seule
certains anciens élèves et aujourd'hui
généreux donateurs ont fait de même
merci beaucoup Tam Tran Laurence je me
tourne vers vous comment vous analysez
ce qui est en train de se passer dans
ces grandes universités américaine c'est
ce sont pas des petites écoles donc il
faut mettre un peu en contexte c'est le
cas de le dire ce qui s'est passé
Harvard mit et Pen ça forme les leaders
de demain donc à partir du moment où
cette génération qui va être éduquée par
les plus grandes universités ne soutient
pas Israël on est dans un changement
profond total de la démocratie
américaine je suis suis personnellement
certaine que il va y avoir un drame aux
États-Unis sur le conflit du Proche
Orient pourquoi parce que les gens sont
arm il y a une importation parce que
l'émotion est intense parce que jour
après jour il y a de plus en plus
d'incident oui il y a quelqu'un qui
poignarde quelqu'un d'autre et là c'est
côté israélien mais il y a eu côté
palestinien il y a trois jeunes
étudiants qui ont été attaqués dont un
qui va être paralysé à vie dans le
Vermont il y a 15 jours il y a une
émotion considérable tout est mis sur
les réseaux sociaux il y a maintenant
ces trois présidentes d'université qui
symbolisent l'élite intellectuelle
américaine qui disent finalement sur les
campus ce qui se passe crétiquer Israël
c'est bien il y a les donateurs riches
qui évidemment vont retirer leurs fonds
on est dans un changement total de
société sur fond de campagne électorale
parce que je rappelle quand même que la
jeune femme qui a fait la commission
parlementaire Élise qu'on vient de voir
c'est d'une certaine manière la création
de Donald Trump c'est-à-dire que c'est
une trumpiste avérée qui a déjà fait du
blocage parlementaire pour Donald Trump
et donc tout ça sur cette campagne
présidentielle qui commence puisqu'on
est maintenant à 10 mois de la campagne
présidentielle avec ce conflit du
proche- Orient qui divise la démocratie
américaine ça ne peut donner rien de bon
je suis très inquiète sur ce qui peut se
passer aux États-Unis dans les semaines
qui viennent ça peut vraiment exploser
et quand ça va exploser aux États-Unis
ça sera violent HM euh et c'est dans
enfin voilà on est dans dans dans le
contexte de ces de de ça c'était mardi
aujourd'hui euh euh au Congrès on est on
est dans un constat d'incapacité du
Congrès américain à débloquer une aide
qui était prévu de 106 milliards de
dollars pour Israël mais aussi pour
l'Ukraine hein c'était la la tentative
de Joe Biden de lier euh les deux je
vous propose d'entendre le chef
démocrate du Sénat qui dit sa
déception ce soir est un triste soir
dans l'histoire du Sénat et de notre
pays les républicains viennent de
bloquer une proposition cruciale pour
envoyer des fonds à l'Ukraine des fonds
à Israël de l'aide humanitaire pour les
civils innocent de Gaza et des fonds
pour
l'Indo-Pacifique euh qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire à di Levalois que l'aide à
Israël est prisonnière de de d'enjeux
politiques intérieur américains c'est
aussi ça qui qui est en train de se
jouer oui puis enfin on voit bien
qu'effectivement C espèce de package que
voulait faire passer Biden donc de
l'aide à l'Ukraine et l'aide à à Israël
et aujourd'hui contesté avec cette
décision qui pris donc c'est vrai que
c'est quand même très ça pose beaucoup
de questions finalement sur le rôle que
peuvent jouer que jouent et qu'on vont
pouvoir jouer les Américains euh sur ce
conflit israël-palestinien même si je
continue à penser qu'ils peuvent faire
quelque chose en la matière mais on voit
bien que les enjeux de politique
intérieure sont en train de prendre le
dessus et comme vient le le rappeler
Laurence Saim effectivement on est en
précampagne électorale donc donc c'est
ce qui risque de bloquer aussi peut-être
des initiatives dans le cadre de la
marge de manœuvre que pourrait à ir ou
prendre les amécs ce je voudrais très
rapidementter très vite parce qu'on a
encore beaucoup de chose à dire et c'est
quasiment la fin du débat trs r c'est
que Biden ne peut pas passer sans faire
des concessions à cette gauche démocrate
qui ne soutient pas Israël et c'est le
problème et donc les trumpist de manière
très habile sont en train de comprendre
sont
en il faut tenir compte du poids des
opinions mondiales c'est aussi ce qu'on
peut dire dans dans dans les dans la
gestion à moyen terme de ce conflit oui
on s'interroge souvent sur pourquoi on
parle tant parfois de de du conflit
israëlpalestinien parce que précisément
il a une dimension universelle il il
affecte les valeurs fondamentales de de
de de beaucoup de gens et que par
conséquent quel que soit le soutien
qu'on puisse exprimer par ailleurs il
mobilise vraiment des valeurs des
sentiments qui sont universels et dans
le cas américain il y a aussi un part
trois trois éléments de particularisme
je trouve premièrement soutien condition
tion à Israël qui qui une marque de
fabrique une l'identité de la politique
étrangère américaine deuxième élément ça
a été rappelé une liberté d'expression
conçu de manière absolue donc qui peut
donner lieu à des abus du point de vue
de notre point de vue parce que la
liberté d'expression est encadré en
France beaucoup plus encadré et et en
même temps il y a un écho par rapport à
la manière dont ce conflit résonne en
France également parce que mine de rien
à travers les échanges qu'on a entendu
ça fait é coup à la teneur de de du
débat auquel a donné lieu et continue de
donner lieu ce conflit on a du mal à
avoir des débats sereins comme celui
qu'on qu'on a ici
régulièrement mais il faut avouer que ça
reste ça relève presque du défi parfois
parce que précisément ça mobilise alors
non seulement des valeurs mais aussi des
éléments
passionnels or dès lors qu'on parle de
passion c'est encore une fois la
question démocratique qui se pose et moi
encore une fois j'y reviens parce que ça
reste a ce conflit sape notre nos
démocraties elle ne il ne fait pas de
bien ni à la démocratie israélienne mais
ni à nos démocraties allez on parle de
la France pour terminer avec vous Émilie
Emmanuel Macron qui a récemment durci le
ton vis-à-vis d'Israël oui il il a
changé à nouveau de ton je dois dire
c'est difficile un peu de de suivre ce
mouvement alors c'était lors de la COP
28 à Dubaï la semaine dernière alors que
le ministère de la Santé de Gaza annoncé
plus de 15000 morts de leur côté depuis
le début du conflit on l'écoute tout de
suite je pense qu'on est à un moment où
les autorités israéliennes vont devoir
définir plus précisément leur objectif
et l'état final recherché la destruction
totale du Hamas qu'est-ce que c'est
est-ce que quelqu'un pense que c'est
possible si c'est ça la guerre durera 10
ans donc il demande à Israël de de
préciser son objectif alors pour celui
qui s'en serait arrêté juste après
l'attaque du 7 octobre au soutien appuyé
voire inconditionnel à Israël difficile
d'y comprendre quelque chose d'autant
qu'entre les deux il y a aussi eu des
changements avec une tentative de
rééquilibrage hein quand il a fait son
voyage son déplacement au Proche Orient
et aussi la proposition qui avait pas
été forcément très bien préparée de
lancer une coalition internationale
contre le Hamas évidemment proposition
très mal perçu par les pays arabes euh
pourquoi ces revirements alors c'est
difficile pour le président de toute
façon de peser dans le conflit ça c'est
clair et il a cette envie très forte
qu'on lui connaît hein de marquer
l'histoire on se souvient de ces
déclarations au Liban qui avaient été
sans effet ou bien de ses conversations
filmées mais malheureuses avec Poutine
des négociations il aurait aimé cette
fois-ci pouvoir organiser le jour
d'après la guerre il y ACC crru
notamment avec la brève trêve qui a eu
lieu entre Israël et le Hamas pour la
libération des otages malheureusement la
reprise du conflit ça réduit son projet
en cendre est-ce qu'il y a un problème
de méthode pour vous alors la méthode
qui est très chè au gouvernement
peut-être que oui puisque cette fois-ci
la méthode macronienne du en même temps
elle aurait été peut-être souhaitable
pour une situation qui est quand même
bloquée avec d'un d'un côté il s'agirait
en même temps de défendre un pays Israël
qui a été attaqué par le terrorisme et
en même temps de protéger une population
les Palestiniens prise au piège par ce
conflit mais voulant aller trop vite
peut-être ou n'ayant pas conscience de
la portée de ses propos ça on y croit
pas trop plutôt que ce en même temps
pour une fois qui aurait été vraiment
judicieux le président a préféré faire
du en plusieurs temps selon le vent en
fait il a opté pour une position plus ou
moins ferme vis-à-vis de chacun des deux
adversaires selon les réactions du
moment les éléments du jour plutôt
qu'une position équilibrée du en même
temps donc qui serait tenue sur le long
terme résultat bah peu de crédibilité
dans les propos peu de lisibilité et
donc peu de portée une diplomatie un peu
brouillonne maladroite voire débutante
mais bon le problème c'est que ça fait
quand même 6 ans qu'il est à la tête du
gouvernement donc on peut pas parler de
débutant non je pense que c'est une une
diplomatie quelque peu assumée un peu
narcissique hein de vouloir trouver la
solution et parfois mal àroite en tout
cas très aléatoire on va conclure
là-dessus merci beaucoup puis que le
voilà j'ai géré le temps comme j'ai pu
le débat était vraiment passionnant et
je vous en remercie et apaisé et je suis
particulièrement sensible voilà aux
conséquences de vos propos je sais que
c'est pas toujours facile ensuite sur
les réseaux sociaux d'assumer ce que
vous dites sur nos plateaux donc merci
de continuer d'y venir et de nous livrer
vos analyses et et la finesse de vos
analyses merci à tous je vais rappeler
naab le titre de votre livre relations
international droit théorie et pratique
paru aux éditions pédon à bientôt sur
sur Public Sénat sans